i mean i think there's a way to
sort of sum up casey the way he's always
been i think it's just one word it's
just
hustle you know yeah well i'm trying to
turn that off stevo
yeah actually i'm curious about that so
with turning off this
like stopping the daily vlogging to
reset your brain to just be in the world
and not be thinking about a vlog all the
time
like how long is that transition and
were there some things that like surfing
where it's like you do it because you
love it you're not even filming were
there some things where you're like
oh wow i actually like doing this
because now i'm not filming it but i'm
still doing it like i didn't even
realize i actually really like this one
thing
you know yeah like my wife is a good
example of that
i'm not even joking i'm totally [__]
serious
like spending time with her but no we
were on the
like verge of divorce the entire
vlog chapter of my life like right on
the edge of divorce
and i would do everything i could to
appease her and i do mean appease
because i didn't i wasn't invested in
like fixing the relationship or anything
like that i just needed her to like
not be pissed at me for today so i could
put her in the vlog
and that sounds like the most awful
thing but i'm just being honest like
that's literally what it was
and now like i like hanging out with her
like i tweeted after i quit vlogging
that like
been spending time with my wife turns
out she's pretty cool and like
everybody's like
lol ha ha and i'm like no i'm [__]
totally serious and so stuff like that
socializing
like i never socialized like i literally
cut every friend out of my
life out of my life unless they were
good on camera
because like i don't have time to hang
out with friends like i need to make
content
i agree with that completely and i mean
he's like he cut out all his friends i
don't know just like
you know the idea there's certain people
they're like hey you know let's hang out
and and it's not a question of whether
they're good on camera it's just
like i i'm on this
planet i'm i'm in this body like
to make [__] happen and like if if a
person
isn't contributing to like me
accomplishing
some kind of a goal that matters to me
then [__] no i don't want to chat
over dinner you know it's not about
being on camera it's just about
being like goal-oriented it's
unproductive
in a conversation or spending time
socializing
because that doesn't that doesn't
advance uh
our [__] objective a goal is that
something you ever hope
to turn off or you're just riding it you
know what i mean like
i feel so strongly about that and then
but but the difference is like with my
with my girl i'm in a relationship with
lux
and like like man like with you guys
like we don't have to be working i love
being around you guys
yeah but i do not want to bring more
people
into that circle i just don't have an
interest in that
i only want to work seven days a week
for the rest of my entire day scott and
i both
i'm so different from you guys we talked
about that now
i got a vasectomy because i'm so sure
that i don't want to have to i
appreciate that
i just like working so much that like
that's all i want to do
because i think that's how i get my
validation but i also enjoy it and like
people are like dude you want to hang
out you know go to a restaurant i'm like
i'm in bed by like 8 39 so i can wake up
at like four or five to field
new york emails or like there's a guy in
australia that we like i
enjoy the [__] out of that and i only
want to do that
i so i think that that's the answer it's
like you got to figure out what you love
doing and there's a couple of things
that i always subscribe to
really like emphatically very
consciously um
one of which is like i my goal in life
is to do
only exactly what i want to do at any
given time like there's this woody
guthrie quote
that maybe bob dylan or somebody like
that stole but it goes like
the definition of success is to wake up
in the morning go to bed at night and in
between
do what you want to do i think you said
the definition of freedom
is to wake up at night go to wake up in
the morning go to bed at night in
between do what you want to do
and to me it's kind of my ultimate so
like that hustle
especially that hustle that like i
really promoted and
glorified and romanticized in like my
vlog and everything that i represented
like you're doing these ted talk looking
things oh yeah like you never said no to
anything i was just going
like 10 jobs and i love you he said like
here's why i am here
i want to be and in between that is just
a whole bunch of work
and when i when i see you say that i'm
like [__] yeah there is
but you you have how many subscribers on
youtube to almost 12 million now
sorry so so would you have the same
mentality of like well i
only want to do what i want to do if you
had like fifty thousand or no
that's what i'm driving towards is like
this clarity that i've always had in my
life in the last video i made in new
york city
where where i actually move out to
california like i talk about
this i was so aware
that like that hustle was a sprint for
me like i'm a big runner i used to be a
competitive endurance runner like i said
literally compete
and you get your sprints and then you've
got like your longer races and like
i was competitive in triathlons at
sprint distance i would win those but
the iron man's 140 mile race my only
objective
was to finish confidently so therefore
like it's about pacing and about being
smart
i always understood like the hustle part
of my life the new york city chapter
like that
whether it was being my startup whether
it was a startup i had before that the
startup i had before that whether it's
my hbo series my youtube series
that was a [__] sprint and the finish
line at the end of that is like if i can
get across this finish line
i want a wife i want kids and i want to
chill the [__] out
and i want to effectively retire when i
start my family
and that was the dream and it was like
that came from an amalgam of things like
one was the fact that like when i had my
first kid i was 16 years old and like
i tried to be the best dad i could but
like i'm 16
and i'm getting [__] free milk and
diapers from the state because i can't
afford to buy my kid
milk or diapers like you try but i knew
that i wasn't
the dad that i i could have been because
i had all these limitations around me
so i always had this idea that like i
will sprint until i can get to a place
where i can just [__] chill out my
dad was like
i talked to him yesterday he's still
working you know he's barely retired and
he's 70 almost
and like i never remember anything from
my childhood but him working
so that was what leaving new york was
like that last year in new york where i
said i was miserable because i wanted to
do what i'm doing now which is just that
like
i i have the money like i got that
[__] bag like i i got the youtube
subscriber like i did everything i
wanted to do they're all ticked off the
list
the thing that's on the list right now
that's next up is like
really just like chilling out doing what
i want to do enjoying my life and like
spending time with my family and the
privilege that that is is not lost on me
like to say that even out loud i'm
uncomfortable admitting
that i get to have that life because who
the [__] i'm 40 years old
yeah who the [__] gets to have that at
40. who
my dad literally retired six months ago
and he still doesn't have that
like he's trying to find a part-time job
right now and he's like it'll just make
things a little bit easier
like he doesn't have that and he's
staring at his twilight years like
i have that right now like i'm totally
[__] healthy and fit there's nothing
wrong with me
my wife's still hot like we're still
young like and i have that that's insane
that's [__] insane so to not hit the
brakes and be like i [__] did that
yeah but to have something which is like
no now is the time to hustle it's like
no [__] i got nothing left to
prove
and what's crazy is like for me i'm such
a
like a guy of extremes i'm so scared of
like
fame right now like i'm so relaxed part
of the reason why i'm struggling to make
youtube's videos right now it's like
i don't want to put myself out there i
don't want to be recognized i don't want
people to talk to me i don't want people
to look at me anymore
like i did that that was cool i tried it
like i got to try fame
frame is amazing right no one's trading
it in
no one's trading it but like but like an
answer dude
i just wanted to try it and like i got
to try it like i got to be like a
somewhat famous like c-level celebrity
for a minute
and i i didn't really like okay let's
turn that off and it's like it kind of
bumps me up that i don't know how to
turn that off besides like
trying not to further it but like i got
to try that and that's really special
i got to know what it's like to run a
company i got to do all these things
like
i just need to appreciate that because i
don't know if like
maintaining that cadence is is i do know
that it's just not interesting to me
right now yeah cool
what's that big dude sorry to cut you
off i know you're gonna say something
but i was
there's a guy in like the 30s he
interviewed like
all the billionaires of the day and he
he they asked him what the definition of
success was and it was peace of mind
yeah i always liked that you know
because no matter he's like
no matter how rich these people were
like back in the day
he's like they literally almost lost
their mind at the end of their life
trying to figure out what to do with
their money
and give it away to different organ
organizations or people that it wouldn't
kill them
because it's just so much for somebody
to handle you know
yeah what's that dale day lewis um there
will be blood yeah
yeah this literally the [__] movie is
that in this guy's pursuit
of money or his ver the only version of
success that he understood
he lost everything every person that was
close to him his family his son
his partners his friends everything and
the movie literally ends
with him sitting by himself over a dead
body
and he looks to the camera and says i'm
finished
and like there's not like that's not
that far of a [__] abstraction like
they're that's real
you drink their milkshake dude they
kindly i drank your milkshake
to like constantly be gut checking how
do i define
success right now like that ted talk
you're talking about defined success
then really acutely because it was
something to
for me success right now is like can i
be a good dad can i be a good husband
and can i be present
and that's such like a wishy-washy
[__] new age stupid thing to say
but like i never got to do that and i
look back at those hustle years that
like
i'm so guilty of romanticizing and like
the reality was like there's a lot of
glory the glory is all anybody saw
including me
but the reality of the day to day was
[__] misery
it was shutting out anyone like you want
to have a conversation with me i'll look
you in the eye and nod my head
all i'm thinking about is how the [__]
um it's interesting and i i don't need
to like get go uh
off on a big thing but for me probably
the most uncomfortable question
is are you happy you know and that's
probably like the definition of success
is to be happy yeah
and when people ask me if i am happy i
think
for many many years i it just made me
uncomfortable every
like uh you know but then i realized
what my answer is
and the answer is no i'm not [__]
happy because what the what's that gonna
get me like content content and i'm
gonna [__]
like stop like laying down like oh i
don't need to do anymore you're like
[__] no like i'm so grateful that i'm
not happy
because that's the that's the drive
that's the fire under my ass i'm not i
never want to be [__] happy
[__] happy he's about to drink
everybody's milkshake
and and uh you know i i love that that
you're so
you know serious about this you know
like that you are content
then i just want to chill and maybe i
can get there one day but uh well
that's why the first question i had was
like you guys have kids is because i
think it
kids aren't for everybody believe me not
entirely sure my mother should have had
kids
thanks mom i appreciate it but if we
could go back and do it over again
maybe skip the whole kids thing um that
said like when you
have kids there's oh my god there's an
instant and in that instant for the
first time in your whole [__] life
your priority is no longer yourself like
i don't care how much you love other
people how much you love
you know relationships anything you have
in your life
there's nothing that can sort of fill
that void that is like you are literally
responsible for this
human that you created that is
completely [__] vulnerable you're 100
on the hook and that shifts your
thinking so i
i think steve like the reason why i can
[Music]
so aggressively pursue a kind of
contentment or happiness
is only because i have these this lens
to look through and it's the lens of
like these
these three kids that i have i mean if
only every parent felt that way
i don't think they have the luxury i
think most have to work and like deal
with reality is that i'm just really
lucky to have
[__] manipulated life around and i
think that there's there are two a lot
of parents that just don't see it
or they just you know remain
so self-absorbed and not like you know
they're just shitty parents and
you know like yeah i think you should
you have to get a license to catch a
fish i think you should have to get a
license to become a [__] parent but
you don't and what are you gonna do
it's making a baby is so easy it takes
me like 15 seconds
it's called stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude